hello and welcome to this video playing
psyched psyched is no name in there even
though I think there's a german player
with that the name ok so i'm playing
this system which is a bit dicey but a
little bit more interesting than many
other lines oh let's see girls are doing
here d3 i'm a 44 or what's not doing you
hmm ok might be five set a deal and
maybe it is
yeah that's okay but why is doing it is
kind of okay so I got a decent
development and no particular problems
not quite clear what my plan is in this
position Queen B 6 doesn't do anything
right stumble into stuff let's play some
improving moose this one okay do you
fall hmm doesn't do much okay it's very
ok for watching this position hmm how do
I play this my night on c7 looks wrong
what's this s6 have six and g5 here
maybe this is this is at least
complicating matters yeah oh it just
takes it okay not a bad move i mean i
just didn't didn't really have it on the
right out well here at least i have some
idea how i might win this game I've got
the bishop pair even though this is not
super important at the moment really I
used sacrificing now or what's the deal
before maybe you for coming but I have G
for some and quite get it it looks scary
I mean it absolutely does check okay and
that's not working don't give me that
one taking here right then it's a bit
much yeah that was very scary i think
yeah he might have had something there
even here's some foi still looking
somewhat scary nuh okay so how do I get
rid of this Bishop to e6 I guess first
the rook nope doesn't make much sense
actually and
let's break the pin immediately and yeah
that's it safe that's already safe now I
can take here right
Queen chef 6cyl and teachers taking this
also care yeah that's okay
Queen 25 maybe and then m8 Scota Giden
now third check out something normal ok
then I can go for an attack yeah that's
g3 is not defend defend the wall white
resides either to add a somewhat shaky
position i think around here this is I
mean maybe it's good i'm not quite sure
what it looks a little bit shaky if i
can consolidate this and I mean if I'm
not having any direct problems the next
three four five moves then I'm okay with
my bishops but it looks shaky and where
h5 doesn't work in after g5 I'm already
winning yeah thing is I'm threatening
this which is the fork on those but also
if the 93 has to move the default is
dropping so it's kind of I don't think
that I was worried about was some kind
of I mean some kind of stuff like that
but it just doesn't work so probably i'm
just very okay he doesn't he doesn't
have to play at five though the engine
wants to play this move which makes an
awful lot of sense so blocks the pawn
and the engines has wide slided better
after Queen to d8 which is a slightly
mysterious looking move what's the deal
and this then I can do this check check
okay so I'm just playing a pawn down
here okay
they had not sure that I've would have
gone for that yeah okay the whole
opening is a is very non theoretical I'm
just with just a play here which is not
a bad thing if you want to be the
somewhat weaker player but he had a good
position I mean you did a good job here
Bishop e5 surprised me but this is
playable i mean the the pieces that he
has remaining are very okay so i think
you did everything right until he played
age fire after this it seems I'm winning
this is just too much material okay well
thanks for watching